r si la parole est à monsieur alain
marty merci merci monsieur le président
chers collègues ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre c'est la dernière
question des républicains sur le bilan
de votre action gouvernementale durant
le quinquennat de françois hollande le
nombre des chômeurs écoutez bien a
augmenté d'un million cent cinquante
quatre mille personnes catégories à b et
c ce sont les chiffres de la dares
les français sont les champions d'europe
des charges et des taxes sur une année
les français donnent plus de la moitié
de leur salaire à l'état un des
engagements de françois hollande était
le retour à l'équilibré budgétaire
nous en sommes loin chacun ici c'est que
nos communes ont vu des baisses massives
de dotation qui nous amène dans de
grandes difficultés
je rends hommage aux conseils au
personnel communal qui aide les élus à
avoir une gestion rigoureuse pour
essayer de préserver quelques crédits
d'investissement devant ce bilan je
connais votre dianétique votre
dialectique c'est enjolivé votre bilan
et critiquer vos prédécesseurs ce jeu
politicien fait réagir votre majorité
qui a besoin de la méthode coué
nos concitoyens ne sont pas dus pour
autant dans ma circonscription je
rencontre aucun habitant qui partagent
vos éléments de langage d'ailleurs les
candidats de gauche à l'élection
présidentielle défendent nullement votre
bilan il le critique où ils sont
étrangement muet je vais vous poser une
question simple et j'espère en fin de
législature avoir une réponse
si votre ville en vous paraît
satisfaisant pourquoi françois hollande
at il décidé de ne pas le défendre
devant les français en renonçant de se
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
la parole est à monsieur christian
équerre secrétaire d'état chargé du
budget et des sosies monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le député marty
tout d'abord je suis obligé de le faire
le premier ministre vous le savez il
l'avait annoncé la semaine dernière et
en chine et ne peux vous répondre
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances est pris par des engagements
internationaux cet après midi et vous
prie de l'excuser
ceci étant monsieur le le député ce
gouvernement n'a pas besoin de porte
parolat parmi les candidats ou ailleurs
pour défendre son bilan son bilan nous
vous l'avons déjà dit c'est d'avoir un
redresser les comptes publics de façon
substantielle est extraordinaire deux
d'avoir redonner de la compétitivité à
nos entreprises comme jamais comme
jamais monsieur le député d'avoir mis en
place à son talent de soutien aux
filières des plans de formation en lien
avec les régions et c'est la fierté de
ce gouvernement
après avoir trouvé c'est vrai vous
l'avez d'ailleurs rappelé une situation
désastreuse
nous avons tout fait pour redonner à ce
pays un espoir de redressement à la fois
des contes de la compétitivité et donc
de l'économie
alors vous pouvez toujours prendre des
propos chalet d'hyères politiciens pour
aller chercher telle ou telle
contradiction à l'intérieur de la
majorité d'aujourd'hui mais je voudrais
puisque vous avez puisque vous avez fait
allusion à la relation entre l'état les
collectivités locales signaler que je
n'ai pas trouvé beaucoup de cohérence
entre les plans d'économies proposées
par vos candidats et les engagements de
réduction de la dépense publique
notamment en direction des collectivités
territoriales
monsieur le député rassurez vous vous
êtes lorrains comme moi moi en lorraine
je connais des candidats et des citoyens
qui défendent le bilan du gouvernement
merci monsieur nice et pour la dernière
question de cette législature